I'm representing Marlon Brando this
evening he very regretfully cannot
accept this very generous award saw
Sheen littlefeather the Native American
activist who famously declined Marlon
Brando's Oscar in 1973 has died she was
75 years old I have said to myself often
times that I never wanted to be bored in
life
and I never have been bored in my life
The Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences announced little feather's
death on Twitter according to the
Hollywood Reporter she died on Sunday in
Northern California after a long battle
with breast cancer
[Music]
hello my name is sasheen littlefeather
it's been nearly 50 years since Little
Feather then 26 took the stage in place
of Brando who won the best actor Oscar
for The Godfather he has asked me to
tell you in a very long speech which I
cannot share with you presently
because of time but I will be glad to
share with the Press afterwards that he
very regretfully cannot accept this very
generous award instead Brando wanted
littlefeather to deliver an important
message on his behalf the reasons for
this being are the treatment of American
Indians today by the film industry
excuse me and on television in movie
reruns
and also with recent happenings at
Wounded Knee but following
littlefeather's Act of protest she was
blacklisted from the industry and just
weeks before her death Academy president
David Rubin issued a letter writing in
part quote you made a powerful statement
that continues to remind us of the
necessity of respect and the importance
of human dignity the abuse you endured
because of this statement was
unwarranted and unjustified the
emotional burden you have lived through
and the cost to your own career in our
industry are irreparable for too long
the courage you showed has been
unacknowledged for this we offer both
our deepest apologies and our sincere
admiration I paid the price of admission
so that others
could follow and that others would
follow in my St my footsteps because of
what I had done and at in time it would
be recognized
in time the doors would be open
and in time
the things that I wanted back then
would become a reality